what's going on guys this is rob and
before we get into this video just a
quick little statement here buddy of
mine vince is going to be competing in
the world air hockey championships this
coming weekend and the champion himself
is actually going to be streaming on his
youtube channel so i'll post a link in
the description make sure you guys check
it out and let's get into the video
what's going on guys this is rob and as
promised we are back with part two of
jerry dugan's x-men run now after this
that's when we start basically the whole
x-men versus avengers versus eternals
judgement day event which is amazing
it's an absolutely amazing story so
here's the thing right like i said in
the last video that we were gonna split
x-men in two because this one starts to
deal with nightmare and then kind of
picks up with a few other things feilong
and stuff like that we'll talk about
them as time goes on but what this does
is it initially joins up with the idea
of nightmare this is something that we
almost never see in marvel comics and in
fact i can't really think of a single
instance where nightmares specifically
targeted the x-men it's not to say he
didn't i just can't think of one off the
top of my head but the thing about this
is it's really just kind of picking up
with the idea of the x-men having their
own individual dreams nightmares things
like that so on and so forth so like
cyclops when he experienced the whole
thing with his brother havoc when or
really alex when they were basically
thrown out of the burning plane by their
parents basically as origin from way
back in the day just all these small
little moments here even jean grey is
having these dreams and nightmares when
she was the dark phoenix and incinerated
all these innocent people and so on and
so forth and all of it's being observed
by nightmare himself now i'm not i'm not
gonna be i'm not gonna lie here guys
like it is a little strange to see
nightmare going after the x-men but it
is cool and it actually makes perfect
sense when you think about it because
the x-men have had some of the most
tragic experiences of anybody in the
superhero community is kind of a small
wonder that nightmare hadn't gone after
them earlier and in fact it's really him
just sort of relishing in these
nightmares that they're having using
them to imbue himself with enhanced
power and kind of focusing on them not
only that it's actually focusing on the
dreams between cyclops and jean in the
sense of cyclops himself having
basically had a telepathic affair with
uh emma frost you know when gene gray
was still around and then of course
eventually leaving emma frost and going
back to gene and so on and so forth
right it's just one of these things
where time and time again they've
experienced these horrible things
emotionally mentally physically and so
on and so forth that have gone on to
have a significant impact on their lives
in terms of how they see the world and
it's one of those things if i'm being
honest with you guys it's one of those
things where in modern day x-men
storytelling you don't really see it
that often right what jerry dugan's
doing here kind of touching on this idea
of nightmare focusing on the emotional
turmoil that the x-men have endured over
the course of their existence this is
chris claremont stuff this is the kind
of stuff that claremont used to do i
mean some writers have done this but
chris claremont's run was very much
things like this not so much with
nightmare but focusing more on the
interpersonal relationships of the x-men
the individual struggles they went
through and the emotional toll that it
takes being a member of the mutant
community out there in the world another
part of this is he focuses on x-23 on
laura kinney who also has a very tragic
past now this is where things get cool
because in the midst of all this
suddenly nightmare's awake and just kind
of jolted by this force that turns out
to be jean grey now this is an important
distinction that i want to make here
right this is a very important thing
that i want to establish here this is
one of those moments in marvel comics
when a writer is coming along and
they're modifying what a character is
capable of a lot of what we've seen jean
grey do regarding her telepathy her
telekinesis even when she was in
possession of the phoenix force and how
powerful the phoenix force is in and of
itself it's usually extrapolation or
direct action so an extrapolation is for
example when rachel summers the daughter
of cyclops and gene from the days of
future past timeline came to the present
day had a phoenix force and then like
fought galactus that's one of those
things when it's kind of like okay gene
could probably do the same thing and
fight galactus to a standstill i think
galactic started feeding on the phoenix
force so rachel had to run away but the
thing about it is like you can sort of
extrapolate that more direct actions are
jean grey with the phoenix facing off
and becoming like the white phoenix of
the crown right like this multiversal
force that exists out there so you can
kind of look at this scenario with
nightmare and look at it in two separate
ways but this is just simply jean grey
by herself absent the power of the
phoenix but lest we forget she is an
omega level telepath and telekinetic and
that's one of the things that i love
about what jerry dugan's doing here
where she's essentially going toe to toe
with nightmare and in fact actually
overpowering nightmare and making this
case and saying you have no sway against
me right there's literally a point where
he starts riding around and just feeding
on the nightmares of all these people
and imbuing himself with more and more
power but gene's still able to overpower
him because when it comes to things like
omega level mutants and so on and so
forth one of the big things that marvel
does is they largely keep it
compartmentalized right like there's a
new omega level mutant there you don't
really see them like face off against
the avengers or something like that
right like overpower the entirety of the
avengers themselves especially when it
comes to like cosmic entities name a
time when you saw an omega level mutant
face off against somebody like eternity
you can count it on one hand so you
don't really see this kind of thing
often seeing an omega-level mutant like
jean grey go toe-to-toe against
nightmare and then overpower him really
gives us this kind of broad perspective
of just how far reaching her power is
how capable she is and how she compares
to other people and so this is one of
those times when you're going to see
this story like this used in like
battles on forums or when someone's
referencing the the power of an omega
level mutant right like jean grey once
overpowered nightmare right so it'll be
like one of those respect threads that
you see going on you'll see this kind of
thing pop up in the future uh when it
comes to different forms and depictions
of what omega level mutants are capable
of but the thing about this is that what
it does is it actually picks up with a
guy by the name of fei long now fay long
is a person who had been contacted by
henry peter geyrick who is part of orcus
now orcas is something that we haven't
really talked about recently and in fact
it was a main focal point of jonathan
hickman's x-men run the long and short
of this is that orcis is basically the
most recent iteration of a
government-backed or really just kind of
an organization that uses government
resources to target the mutant
population and to try to destroy them
right it's a very simplified explanation
of them but that's basically what they
are but unlike things like friends of
humanity or the right or even like the
the federal government with project wide
awake that orcas utilizes resources from
a host of different things so orcas is
composed of people from hydra and
advanced idea mechanics and even people
like henry peter guyer who work for the
federal government just things like that
so it's it's really kind of a more
modern day depiction of project wide
awake but in a more expanded capacity in
so far as who is a part of it who's a
part who's uh joined this whole
organization but for fei long himself
he's kind of a villain but not really
but the idea behind fei long and kind of
a difference between him and a lot of
other people is that fei long was a guy
who at like 13 years old had graduated
like summa [ __ ] laude or magna [ __ ] laude
from like mit he was a genius but it was
one of those things where in effect the
different campaigns that he had gone on
which were largely heroic there were
good campaigns where basically he was
basically beaten to the punch by the
x-men so an example of this was to
essentially terraform mars and to turn
mars into a place that could be used for
like human occupation the x-men beat him
to it and so because of the fact that
the x-men were always sort of beating
him to the punch which would lead to
like his own personal failures
essentially he started targeting the
x-men started going after them so again
he's not really a true villain so much
as really again kind of a chris
claremont era character who hates the
x-men because they've just kind of
screwed him over but one of the things
he does is in order to ensure that he
can terraform mars he had basically
modified his body to adapt to the mars
environment which also gave him the
ability to tap into cosmic energies now
it doesn't make him some massive you
know ridiculously op guy well it
actually kind of does and we'll find out
why here in a minute
but from this point what we end up doing
is actually kind of picking up again
these these kind of last three issues
for four five and six actually kind of
jump between individual stories for
individual characters so they're really
more filler stories going into judgment
day but this basically switches over to
the character of polaris of lorna dane
now one of the things to know about
lorna dane is she's always had a kind of
often on-again off-again relationship
with the x-men one of the more notable
roles that she had in marvel comics is
when she was part of x factor back in
the 1990s which i would argue is
probably the best role she had in truth
ever since then lorna danes just kind of
free-floated from like one group to the
next and marvel never fully knew what to
do with her character which is actually
kind of cool because it gives us a
chance to see her character in different
scenarios and situations that we
wouldn't normally see had she just had
marvel found a specific place for her
but the thing about this is that in the
midst of this fight against the reavers
which by the way for those of you guys
who are unfamiliar with him and the old
uncanny x-men stories the reavers
initially started out as basically
cybernetic henchmen of the hellfire club
the reavers have just kind of been this
looming ongoing threat that were really
really prominent in the 1980s and then
stopped being important later on i mean
they were kind of a big deal during
x-men the animated series and as far as
the comics went because they were
popular in the show but by the time you
got to like the mid to late 1990s they
were just this long forgotten concept
that existed and they would pop up from
time to time but they would never matter
the important thing here is their small
time right like at the moment they're
basically working for a government and
they're looking to do what goes on there
where they make life hell for mutants in
that location and so on and so forth and
so the x-men are kind of responding here
right it's just sort of what the x-men
are doing at this point in time the
reason why this matters is because for
the character of lorna dayne one of the
things she does is because you have
adamantium in the body of uh of x-23
albeit not laced to her skeleton per se
but more just the claws that she has
that what you have is lorna dane who
literally uses her body as a puppet and
basically goes after the individual
members of the reavers and basically
kind of takes them out now of course
what also ends up happening here is you
basically have her working alongside or
really just kind of dealing with this
giant nuclear meltdown that goes on she
kind of saves that it's a lot of like
quick little events that happen in
succession but the larger reason why
this matters and the bigger reason why
it's important here is because even
after the defeat of the reavers with her
basically using x-23 as a bit of a
puppet is because during the hellfire
gala when the the various mutants who
were who were there were voting
telepathically on who the next x-men
roster was going to be or who was going
to be on the next team lorna dane was
just kind of like please not me and that
jean grey had actually modified her
thoughts to say yes i want to be on the
team so lorna dane was basically thrown
on the new x-men team the reason why
this is important is because she's
always been a character who has been a
little unsure of herself and what her
role is and that's why polaris has been
as much a villain as a hero in marvel
comics because the way her character's
been written over the years is that on a
personal level her loyalty shift because
she doesn't quite know where she stands
she's kind of like an in comic book
variation of how she resides in the
publishing landscape of we just don't
know what to do with this chick right
that's basically what it is here and so
that's when you have this conversation
that takes place between jean grey and
polaris where she asked the question
like why did you mess up my thoughts to
put me on this team right like why did
you why did you do that and the
responsive gene is because you need the
x-men as much as the x-men need you it's
really what this is and the reality here
is that your initial thought was i want
to be on the x-men but then you talked
yourself out of it with your second
thought which was please not me so i
went with your original impulse and the
reality is that gene gray's right here
right i mean this is one of the reasons
why jean grey and the modern era of
x-men storytelling is so much better
than she used to be because the truth is
that she's just wildly intriguing right
like she's just wildly fascinating and
she plays a far more prominent role than
she used to really outside of the
phoenix force it's why i tell people all
the time right people ask me my thoughts
on jean and i say look in the old
stanley jack kirby run she sucked during
the chris claremont era she was amazing
until she died which was about i'd say
about 60 or so issues into his run and
then in turn she came back as part of x
factor she was kind of cool a little bit
but the truth about it is that with the
exception of stories like x-men here
comes tomorrow or like phoenix in song
and war song or something like that that
jean grey had not had a significant run
or significant value to the x-men for
quite some time this really changes a
lot of things in terms of how she looks
so that's one of the things that i do
love about this but she is also accurate
in talking to polaris about this which
is you need to be on the x-men right you
need to be a part of this team because
you need a sense of belonging that's
what you lack you lack that sense of
belonging you lack that sense of purpose
need like you don't really feel like
anybody wants you but the x-men do and
this will give you the feeling of family
that you've never really had and a place
to in a place to belong so it is a cool
thing right this is really more about
the evolution of polaris than anything
else the big thing that comes into play
here right the big thing that matters
here is the character of captain krakow
now here's the thing all the illusions
here put forward the idea that captain
krakow is a massively powerful omega
level character we will get his origin
right we will actually get the origin of
uh of of captain krakow but it's one of
those cool things where basically
there's like a cat stuck in a tree and
captain krakow just kind of shows up and
then rescues this cat and like that's
basically it the captain of kakoa has
the ability to fly and all that kind of
stuff now of course flying does not
necessarily elevate him to omega level
status right like i mean like imagine
that right like beyond omega level
anybody who has the ability to fly
right like it doesn't really work that
way but the things he does right is
basically manipulating what is in effect
the crocodile island itself and that's
where a lot of the potential beyond
omega level perception becomes from at
least seems to come from is because the
island of krakowa is itself an omega
level thing right it's a giant landmass
it can never truly be destroyed right
like it provides life and all kinds of
stuff it's not your traditional
depiction of an omega level being right
where it's just ridiculously powerful
and can like alter reality or anything
like that but it still falls in that
vein the thing to understand here though
is that we're basically experiencing
what isn't what is essentially a six day
time gap now we're not told explicitly
what happens in this six day time gap
but what we are told is this that ben
urich right the reporter that we talked
about in the previous video that we had
lightly glossed over that the reason why
we kind of postponed it to this video is
that what ben uric has been doing is
investigating krakowen resurrection
because that's one of the things to know
the world itself does not know that
x-men have the ability to resurrect each
other right they don't know that they
don't know that when an x-man or a
mutant dies they can be resurrected in
krakowa and a lot of that's because
whenever mutants die they usually die in
on some kind of a mission away from
prying eyes it's in secret or something
like that and that's effectively it no
one knows that they have the ability to
resurrect what ben uric has been doing
is investigating that because one of the
things that had happened here that's one
of the reasons why we kind of avoided
that avoided that bit of a time skip is
that ben urich had been discovering what
were basically the corpses of
of mutants albeit not necessarily laid
everywhere but discovering mutants that
were supposed to have been dead but were
basically walking around a really good
example of this is the grave of nathan
summers which was empty so why bury a
man that's not dead and so ben uric ever
the detective right over the the
journalist right ends up coming to this
realization that what seems to be going
on and while he doesn't really have any
evidence to support it what seems to be
going on is that x-men have mastered the
ability to defy death they've mastered
the ability to resurrect themselves and
that's why he goes to cyclops and is
like we need to talk about this and
cyclops is like there's nothing to talk
about i don't i don't know what you're
talking about right like we don't have
the ability to resurrect each other from
the dead and that's even when ben york's
like but i know you can so what i'll do
is i'll give you a few days and i will
let you come up with any kind of
statement that you want to offer if you
want to offer one but i've got to go
public with this i can't keep this to
myself this will win me a pulitzer prize
the idea that death has been conquered
and people can be resurrected if the
world becomes aware of this they will go
after krakowa explicitly for that right
just as much as they would if krakowa
had waged war against the world because
now what you're talking about is the
removal of death if krakowa has the
ability to resurrect people from the
dead imagine your loved ones right like
politicians will play on that they'll be
like well imagine if you could bring
back the daughter you lost or the son
you lost or something along those lines
albeit vying for power the average
person will go after it because the
average person is selfish and they're
usually an idiot so they'll go after it
before no other reason than the fact
that like they just want it right
that'll that'll just be it'll just be
the most basic human desire right i mean
it's you know that's kind of how people
are it's just the nature of human beings
it doesn't make it okay but you know hey
what are you gonna do so the thing about
this is
that cyclops of course kind of shut them
down and then what it ended up happening
is that during this six day time jump
something took place where cyclops died
now under normal circumstances the quiet
council would resurrect him but they
couldn't and the reason why is because
cyclops death was public the whole like
everybody saw it happen it was out there
public in the face of the world and
because cyclops death was so public if
he had suddenly just came walking back
out again right walking around like hey
everybody it's me cyclops i know you
think you saw me die but you know i
don't know magic people would start
asking questions right and they'd start
asking the wrong kinds of questions how
is it that we could watch this guy die
and then in turn he comes right back and
the reality here is the quiet council is
already aware that ben yurick is trying
to find some evidence for this pulitzer
prize-winning article about how the
x-men have conquered death and all it's
gonna take is for that article to come
out people are gonna put two and two
together they're gonna come after kakoa
because that's when people are going to
definitively know krakowa conquered
death and so that's why cyclops is like
i want to be back on the x-men like i
want to go back and rejoin the x-men
team and the response to the quiet
council is no you cannot join the x-men
you cannot be out there in the in public
people can't know you're alive now the
reality here is it's that statement and
then dot dot dot until we can figure out
something to do but in effect that's
where that's where captain krakow came
from is that it's basically the new
superhero mantle of cyclops now as for
how it is that he's able to like fly and
stuff like that that's just using croco
and tech so he doesn't have like a new
set of powers so for all you guys who
hate change in comics don't worry this
is probably only a temporary thing i
know you guys are probably getting ready
to fire up your keyboard i'm tired of
marvel messing with the mutants and
derpy derp derp no this is probably not
going to be a permanent change
everything goes back to normal calm down
enjoy the ride don't forget to have fun
when you're reading comics it's kind of
an important part of the whole process
so what this does is it basically
switches back over to uh really to fei
long himself as well as sunfire and the
reason why is because sunfire of course
basically being on mars which remember
that a portion of the x-men led by storm
and this is actually covered in the
x-men red comic but a portion of the
x-men led by storm had basically
terraformed mars and they they literally
use it as kind of like a secondary base
of operations but the important thing
here is that the desire of fei long is
not necessarily to terraform mars itself
he can't do that anymore if you were to
show up on mars and try to start
terraforming it it would literally bring
them to war with the x-men right it's
like somebody showing up on your
backyard and saying aye i claim this
land in the name of me right and like
taking over your property which is kind
of what happened in north america but
the thing about this is that fei long
ends up basically showing up on phobos
now while again this is not really mars
proper it is of concern to the mutant
population because it's the equivalent
of like basically your sworn enemy
buying the house across the street from
you and spying on you that's basically
what it is right it's literally humanity
trying to get us close to morocco which
is what they call mars now as close to
that place as possible without actually
conquering it or anything along those
lines and so as soon as feiglong shows
up here sunfire is the one that's sent
to intervene and the reality here is
feylong's like i'm here on behalf of
like henry peter geirk and the federal
government but you're not talking me out
of this right it's been my life's
ambition to terraform some place outside
of earth in order for the you know for
the benefit of humanity fat lot of good
you're gonna do trying to stop me from
doing it here and so what this does is
it draws the attention of the citizens
of morocco now remember during jonathan
hickman's run that when it came to a
rocko and krakowa they were at one point
a giant land mass but they had to be
separated in order to save the world
from its imminent destruction that was
done by apocalypse and so when those
forces of oracle basically descended
down into their own dimensional area
they stayed there for eons but during
the events of like ten of swords and all
that stuff during hickman's run a rocko
and krakowa were reunited but the
reality is trying to find or trying to
maintain some balance between the
citizens of morocco and the citizens of
kokoa really just couldn't be done
because they were so starkly different
in terms of how they saw things all
people in morocco knew was war conflict
and death the people of
were from were promoting peace so in a
lot of ways it was like the ideology of
magneto versus the ideology of xavier
spread across like two different
societies and so in order to ensure that
both forces could co-exist at the same
time but they could also maintain their
own individual lifestyles or their own
place that what you saw was the people
of morocco who were sent to mars and
they basically reside there so that's
why you have all these individuals from
morocco from the ten of swords event
that are basically hanging out now of
course one of them is a guy by the name
of vornak now this is one of those
instances where we're kind of introduced
to what what is essentially a citizen of
a rocco that was part of the arakan
group during like at least you know the
whole air the whole time period when
they were banished this is one of those
times those of you guys who are
unfamiliar with this this is one of
those times when we're slowly being
introduced to characters we didn't know
about before for this guy it doesn't
really matter all that much because when
he shows up here one iska kind of puts
off this idea that he's already
exceedingly powerful right of course
it's being one of the more significant
members of morocco but he already has a
history of demonstrating just how
capable he is and she even goes as far
as to say that like song you know songs
are sung about your bravery and like
your feats right like you don't really
have to go and do this no one's gonna
doubt your bravery but the reality here
is that vornack like so many other
members of morocco really just kind of
cherishes combat and violence and
destruction the survival of the fit it's
right testing his might against the
might of others and if he proves himself
to be more powerful than them it's more
of a personal accomplishment as opposed
to how everybody else sees it the kicker
to this is that when he shows up to face
off against fei long that sunfire
initially tries to stop under this fear
that if fei long were to be killed
humanity would take that as an act of
war by the mutant population on mars and
then use that to basically launch an
assault on the mutant population so it's
more politics than anything else
fortunately for us we don't have that
problem because despite all the the
bluster of vornak and everything that
he's capable of fei long incinerates him
with a blast from his mouth using the
cosmic powers that he has he destroys
this guy and that's literally when when
at that point sunfire's like you have
any idea what you've done because i've
got to tell the x-men what's happened
here and now they're going to have to
make a choice do we let this stand or do
we take this as an assault on the mutant
population by humanity right so are we
gonna be inching ever close to war is
this like the first major shot you know
is this is this what is in effect the
assassination of archduke ferdinand that
launched world war one is that what
we're seeing here right that's the
concern of sunfire because he has no
desire to go to war but the reality here
is because of the intelligence of fei
long within days he basically terraforms
the entirety of phobos and turns it into
what is essentially humanity's foothold
out in space so it gives humanity the
ability to spy on mars to spy on the
mutant population now and that's what's
so crazy about this now as i kind of
tail into this and this actually goes
directly into issue number seven which
is the start of a new arc essentially
the origin of captain kakawa that what
happens is that because uh cyclops is
told by the by the quiet council if you
want to operate as a superhero you're
gonna have to operate as that guy but
you're not going to be able to be
cyclops and honestly you shouldn't be
going out there anyway you should not be
showing up as any kind of a superhero in
any capacity because all anybody has to
do is figure out that you're cyclops and
they have the secret of of mutant
resurrection which is why he sneaks in
and out of krakowa it's really just a
captain captain gracoa kind of just
being a moniker he dawned on himself
outside the approval of the council he
basically goes to ben urich contacts him
and says hey i'm a friend of scott
summers also known as cyclops i heard
you're publishing an article about how
cohen's basically managed to to to
master death you know i have some
information that might help you on this
so really kind of forcing the hand of
the quiet council that quite literally
he would dump this information out to
the world in order to maintain himself
in order to stay himself right like
basically doing whatever it takes to win
now what's so crazy about this is ben
urich responds in a really really
cryptic way where we don't know if
something happened to him or if he's
simply just pretending but the response
of ben jurick is i don't know who
cyclops is like i don't know i don't
know your friend he seems like a really
cool guy but my condolences to the fact
that your friend died now there's only
one real possibility that i can think of
here and if it is what i think it is the
x-men are getting nefarious that with
the quiet council realizing that ben
uric is investigating cohen resurrection
that potentially what they did is they
killed him and then they brought him
back using krakow and resurrection tech
and wiped those memories from him and
probably using a little fiddling from
professor xavier put him right back
where he was before so as far as he was
aware he may be passed out whatever it
is but he doesn't recall anything right
like he doesn't know cyclops or at least
he doesn't know anything about cohen
resurrection whatever that case is they
basically wiped his mind maybe it's
maybe it was xavier just using his
telepathic powers right but whatever it
is the x-men are doing everything they
can or at least a quiet council is doing
everything they can to keep all this
covered up pretty nefarious stuff but
with that being said guys we're going to
bring this to an end again this is when
we start getting into judgment day which
i promise this this video i'm not going
to lie was it was kind of cool but
judgment day is really amazing so thank
you guys for watching and i will catch
you all later
peace